and you give your opponent the move so
force them to give ground and that's why
maxine bashley graph is just waiting
with his king now
and uh he's just
kind of saying to magnus you declare
where your king goes and then i'll
commit my king
and uh magnus how is he going to try and
hold on to this game we know that
objectively the bar proves the black is
winning but still black needs to be
accurate one slip in a king and pawn end
game and it can completely go the other
direction it can swing a whole 360.
so
the king moves forward now i expect
black's king to just sidestep again
magnus making that move with less than
20 seconds on his clock
how hard is it to find the right moves
in this situation okay sometimes it can
be hard especially for magnus but maxine
vasily grove has a lot of time and there
we see magnus he gets up he didn't even
resign yet but now we will see the world
champion resign he's in zugswang he has
to give way with his king and he's about
to lose that's why he gives up wow
what a victory from the frenchman a kung